(phone clicking)
- [Voiceover] Drinks. Is that just drinks?
Or, dinner and drinks?
If it's just drinks, I
gotta eat before so I don't
get too dunk, but if it's
dinner then I can't eat before,
or she'll be the only
eating, and that'll be rude.
(woman laughing)
Maybe I bring a bag of trail-mix
and eat it in the bathroom.
I could just ask her, you
know, "Is this dinner?"
But then does that make it a date?
Drinks and dinner, drinks and
dinner, drinks, just dinner.
Whoa, whoa, hey, hey, when
someone says "Let's get drinks."
Does that mean just drinks,
or dinner and drinks?
It's throwing my whole game.
- What time are the drinks?
- [Guy in shorts] 8:30ish.
- 8:30's too late to be dinner,
it's gotta just be drinks.
- You're for sure?
- 100% Sure.
- [Guy in shorts] Just drinks?
- [Guy in jeans] For sure. It's gotta be.
- Alright, I'm going with drinks.
- Okay, bye.
- [Guy in shorts] Just drinks.
- [Guy in shorts] Drinks only drinks.
- Just drinks dude.
- [Guy in shorts] Drinks.
- Oh, well 8:30 could just
be dinner if she's European.
(fast guitar strumming)